un des mérites des manuels macron est
d'avoir compris que la france n'avait
aucun intérêt à perdre du crédit
politique économique en europe et qu'il
fallait en effet poursuivre dans la voie
des progrès qui ont été enregistrés et
sur la compétitivité et sur la
crédiblité budgétaire aujourd'hui la
france en 2010 est peu passée devrait
passer en dessous de 3% que c'est un bon
candidat contre 10 donc c'est le
candidat qui dans la campagne européenne
dans la campagne présidentielle a mis le
plus en avant l'europe et qui essaye de
faire une pédagogie vers les français
que l'europe est bonne pour la france et
que la france a besoin de l'europe que
l'europe a aussi besoin de la france
et ça c'est un mérite que je lui
reconnais depuis longtemps après mon
candidat à moi qui suis un homme de
gauche et un homme européen
c'est celui qui est capable de marier
ces deux aspirations et je souhaite
franchement que dans la pratique on soit
capable d'avoir une europe qui non
seulement soit économiquement plus
pertinente mais qui soit capable de
résoudre ces divergences divergences
nées dans une pierre moscovici ware et
qui soit aussi capable de réduire les
inégalités et de ce point de vue là je
n'ai pas aujourd'hui de programme
vous n'avez pas aujourd'hui votre
candidat de gauche présents à cette
élection présidentielle qui foutent
marierait ces deux options mais si tu ne
retrouves ait pas de candidat c'est pour
ce qui me concerne je constate qu'il ya
une chose c'est que la gauche
sociale-démocrate européenne n'a pas de
candidat dans cette élection
après dans une élection on prend aussi
ceux qui se présentent et on fait des
choix en fonction alors est votre joueur
audois on doit examiner les programmes
j'attends les programmes des autres
puisque finalement d'une certaine façon
emmanuel macron a pris les devants entre
je vois ce qu'il propose je vois la
cohérence je vois c'est une démarche
qu'il faut adopter dans la démarche qui
consiste à présenter un projet à
discuter et débattre de sa cohérence et
que dans ce projet il ya une partie
européenne substantielle donc voilà je
ne suis pas en marche mais je respecte
démarche qui étaient présentes il
l'héritier du la social démocratie à la
françois hollande
il ya des éléments de continuité je les
dis aussi des éléments qui sont
décidément de différencier les aimants
de gauche et de droite donc il prend une
partie de l'héritage ce qui est assez
logique puisqu'il a comme jouer un rôle
dans tout ça il a été conseillé le
président il a été ministre soutient que
les héritiers mais il n'est pas
l'héritier de la gauche social-démocrate
tout simplement parce que lui-même
refuse de se mettre dans cette position
est que il construit une formation
politique qui a plus d'envié valence
certains diraient d'ambiguïté c'est son
choix en tout cas il l'assumé il le
poursuit et ça mérite à tout le moins
d'être considérés respectés examiner